welcome to the David pakman show I Am
David pakman if he dyed his hair red and
got stung by a thousand bees
uh I am Jesse dollamore thanks for
joining me today again I want to thank
David for asking me to to co-host but uh
substitute this week it's uh I'm
flattered I'm honored and I would
appreciate it if you would follow me on
social media I'm at dollar more just
about everywhere from YouTube Twitter
Tick Tock I'm all over the place just at
dollar more today I want to talk about
friend of the program
Mike Lindell or as David would call him
Mike pillow
the Cyber Symposium that has been talked
about for seemingly ever started today
and it was postponed because of
he was hacked according to Mike Lindell
which obviously cannot be trusted
because he is a grifter and a charlatan
and a liar
I'm going to read from this article in
the independent briefly and then I'm
gonna play a couple clips from the
madness that ensued today
Mike pillow excuse me my pillow CEO Mike
Lindell delays start of cyber Symposium
claiming he has been hacked conspiracy
theorist claims there was more evidence
of election malfeasance in November and
December than any crime in history
that's saying a lot considering the the
crimes that we have witnessed throughout
history that Donald Trump losing an
election was the biggest
it says a lot about not just where the
right is right now but also where Mike
Lindell is and before I go on I want to
admonish everybody that if you're listen
I'm a guy I don't mind a few insults I
don't mind flinging a few names here and
there but to impugn this man because he
is a former drug addict I think is
misguided I don't need to come to Mike's
defense like Mike like we're friends
but addiction is a disease addiction
isn't a moral failure and if you're
gonna pick on somebody for something
that shouldn't be it there's plenty of
ammunition to use against Mike Lindell
that doesn't involve
um his struggles with addiction
having said that I want to read a little
bit from this article my pillow CEO and
pro-trump conspiracy theorist Mike
Lindell delayed the start of his
quote-unquote cyber Symposium after
claiming that the whole technology was
attacked
I guess I could do the the Mike Lindell
voice for the quotes
um the whole technology was attacked
yeah because he is like a character from
the movie Fargo
we need to get the word out because they
blocked the thing
uh technologist
futurists understander of modernity and
uh technology they blocked the the thing
but this is part of what I'm going to
talk about today this is a cover-up this
is the absolute cover-up of the worst in
history Mr Lindell told a crowd in South
Dakota on Tuesday the audience had
gathered to hear evidence of for the
baseless conspiracy theory that the 2020
election was stolen from former
president Donald Trump Mr Lindell
claimed that his Symposium will show
that China hacked the election to make
sure that Joe Biden won there's no
evidence of this and election Security
Experts have said that the 2020 election
was one of the safest in U.S history now
I will remind you I'm sure you remember
that in November Donald Trump's own
Department of Homeland Security declared
this election the safest and most secure
in the history of the country
that's saying something
but still these conspiracy Ding Dongs
are running across the country hosting
cyber symposiums with their fake
nonsense their streaming data of just
merely metadata
and attempting to continue to whip the
right into a frenzy into a
conspiratorial rage that we already
witnessed violence at the hands of
these people who believe Donald Trump
lost are the same people who stormed the
capital
harming over 150 police officers
the same people
so this isn't just a fanciful thing of
some Wingnut out there in South Dakota
there are real world
ramifications to this real harm can be
done real lives can be ruined
here's a couple of video clips
the first is when he's announcing the
postponement the short postponement
because of the dreaded hack but we do
have a backup plan it still be probably
another five minutes
and I want all of you guys or all you
guys to know that out there that this is
why because I need to get the word out
we can't even get the word out to the
people that are prankspeech.com because
they block the thing or blocked the
thing
um but this is part of what I'm going to
talk about today this is the cover-up
this is the absolute cover-up of this of
the worst crime in history
and we're going to talk about all this
today this is um and you're going to see
all kinds of things you're going to
educate everybody we're going to show
them the they uh we're going to be
running I'll show you over here you see
this data that's running there that's
cyber data from the from what I've got
let's see if it's moving
um yeah it's not it's not rotating yet
but there's they're going and end the
stream for days and we put Six States up
there
um
but I just we're not going to start the
regular program though because I want to
start because it's all educational and
it all goes in sequence I will say this
everybody tonight you're going to see
something at seven o'clock
that um it's going to change the world
um and um and then also tomorrow
[Applause]
you're gonna
that Applause seems a little tepid
[Laughter]
for the announcement to come on the
heels of the announcement that it's
going to change the world
it changed yeah change the world I'll
give you a little clap uh the other part
that I want to share with you is uh and
I'm laughing by the way because it is
hilarious this man is a funny person he
is objectively Goofy
um someone came to him and said that
we're gonna go to lunch and he refused
in fact he he got aggressive about it
and I'm not taking a long time I'm gonna
live stream
just bizarre they attacked me they
buried it
you think about that
but they got something they want to show
you off stage here okay I guess we have
something off stage but so we're live
streaming though so you want to talk
well I think we're gonna I think we're
set up for a break and maybe we're going
to talk a little bit right when we get
back there we're going to go in no we're
not going on a break put up that movie
again run the movie there's no breaks
we're streaming 72 hours live streaming
so around the world this never stops you
guys can go eat that's fine but I ain't
eating I'm staying up here for 72 hours
before they ruin our signal
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen lunch is now
available in the back hallway thank you
yeah we're gonna put the movie up again
if everybody missed it I want to go put
the movie up fabulation system and then
when we come back from the movie we're
gonna help Dr Frank Street or go he's
going to get on there and do his
presentation so is the movie going it
came together because they are guys this
is the movie y'all heard about this
morning with this movie so no lunch for
Lindell he's too focused on the task at
hand to uncover the world changing data
at his cyber Symposium which by the way
uh is being live streamed by like Steve
Bannon on real America's voice you know
not fake America's voice real America's
voice
one of our sponsors is geology the place
to go for men's skin care geology helps
men find a simple skincare routine that
works it's personalized for you by a
dermatologist and geology can help with
dark puffy eyes acne oily skin
protecting your skin against damage you
answer a few questions about your skin a
dermatologist will design a personalized
skin regimen for your needs you'll get a
30-day trial with the products they
recommend to try them out if you like
how it goes they'll keep sending it to
you these aren't bogus Miracle creams
these are just the clinical
evidence-based products that
dermatologists have at their disposal
but they're tailored personally to you
based on the products you really need I
took the quiz a couple of months ago
their dermatologists matched me with a
regimen that's just great for me I've
been happy with the results my Skin's
looking great I can actually see a
difference go and take geology's free
quiz and when you use my link right
underneath this video you will save up
to 40 percent off your first paid month